反正你爸你妈再提什么要求的话，
你就说妈，
我也想啊，
你以为我不想嘛，
我也想帮我弟弟啊，
可是我没钱，
我现在都还是啃老，
吃的喝的用的都是公公婆婆出的钱，
确实我张不开嘴呀，
我不可能张嘴让我公公婆婆支持我弟弟结婚吧，
你没有这个理儿啊，
我今年30岁，
结婚8年了，
我怎么处理我婆家和我娘家那边的关系，
就是我怎么对他们两个共同的处理，
不是他们两个有矛盾，
我自己的矛盾是我老公是兄弟三个，
我嫁的是老大老二，
和我弟弟是一样大的年纪，
他们两个现在都在订婚和结婚的阶段，
我老公的弟弟要结婚，
我婆婆就把我现在住的婚房让我们搬出去，
但是她已经给我买好婚房了，
就是新的婚房也给我们装修好了，
今年刚装的，
她说你们搬出去让老二住进来，
我结婚的时候是收了六万六的彩礼，
但是这个彩礼呢，
是全部都被我妈妈给拿走了，
她说的理由是她要去给我买嫁妆，
给我做东西，
但是他就给了我几床被子，
嫁妆就给了几床被子，
啊，
对，
就是就只有几床被子，
一个需要垫的家电都没有，
那你家里兄弟姊妹几个，
我有一个弟弟，
但是我不到16岁就出去打工了，
是借着身份证去打个工，
那他六万六的彩礼他收了，
你心里明白吗？
他这六万六就不打算用你身上了，
是不是，
他就是给我买了被子，
我算他一万嘛，
但是他的改口费给。
给我2万，
我儿子出生给了1万，
我儿子过三岁生日给了1万，
这就是全部的大账，
后面就再也没有给我转过钱了，
就是每年是400块钱的压岁钱，
是给我儿子的，
你这样算起来的话，
他其实也给了你5万的大帐了，
我从16岁就打工嘛，
虽然小也存不住钱，
但是就我能存下来的钱就已经全部给他们了，
大概是10万块，
他们给我要的，
因为我不存钱嘛，
他们说你给我吧，
我来帮你存，
以后给你当嫁妆，
我给你爸爸没本事，
没办法给你存嫁妆，
以后你出门有面子嘛。
我想是我确实存不住钱，
我就全部打给他们了，
我有大账，
因为我是支付宝转了，
转了大概10万块。
好，
那你现在是想要问，
现在是我老公的弟弟，
他的女朋友是要13万的彩礼，
就是跟我没关系嘛，
因为我们全家现在是全部在啃老，
我妈妈那边，
我亲弟弟的女朋友要要的是16万的彩礼，
但是我妈妈希望我再去帮助一下我弟弟，
我不知道该怎么去让他知道我的底线，
还有我的原则，
直说呀，
我没钱呀，
我现在都是啃老，
我又没有钱，
他就说你要去帮一下你弟弟呀，
怎么我们对你很不错呀，
我们把你养大了，
我们把彩礼全部都给你了，
虽然不是以押小姐的形式给你的，
但是改口费什么的也都给你啦，
你儿子出生活也给你钱啦，
怎么怎么样，
房那前提条件得我有本事对，
我的房子装修也全部都是我婆婆出的钱，
我们买了五年，
今年是刚装好，
还是改款装的，
对呀，
我觉得这个。
最近就可以实话实说，
妈，
我也想帮，
如果我有100万的话，
我恨不得给我弟弟80万，
可以看我就是老是这样说，
对呀啊，
如果我有1000万的话，
我恨不得1000万都给我弟弟，
可是我没有啊，
我没有这个本事呀。
妈，
我觉得这话真的一点不气人啊，
实话呀，
我要有一个亿的话，
我一个亿都愿意给我弟弟，
可是我没有啊，
我没有这个本事啊。
妈，
我只有这点本事啊，
你们只送我读书，
只送我读到56岁啊，
我在社会上的竞争力也就这样啊，
我只够养活我自己啊，
我没有这个本事啊。
实话直说，
现在就是我爸爸妈妈妈那边，
因为是农村的嘛，
他们没有退休金，
也没有劳保，
然后我公婆是全额的退休金，
他们看病也不花钱，
我要怎么去平衡我妈那边的养老关系，
因为我妈的口气好像需要我给他养老，
我没有这个本事啊，
我没有这个能力啊，
你的房子装好一点，
我和你爸爸还可以去住，
但是我装房子的时候，
他说你装给我，
告诉我，
我们借给你点钱，
我们给你点钱，
然后真到我真的装的时候说哎呀，
你装了真好真好，
你装的挺不错的，
挺好的，
你真棒，
就我跟你说很多东西就是不要开口，
我说这个开口就是不要承诺，
不要承诺说以后你们来我这儿住啊什么的，
不承诺。
对我告诉他的是房子都不是我花钱买的，
我一分钱都没有出，
我做生意，
买房子装修全部都是我公婆出的钱，
我们一家三口什么钱都没有，
我给房子登记在谁的名。
一下呀，
我和我老公的可能会加上我儿子的名字吧，
还没有落户，
现在公公婆婆确实也不错了啊，
你们现在就可以，
公公婆婆是不是就是全部都可以了，
结婚8年，
吃饭住行，
包括老房子新房子，
物业水电全部都是我公婆交的邮费，
我回家的礼品也全部都是我婆婆买的，
8年我没有买过东西，
基本上那自己也没想过挣点钱吗？
没想过干啥工作吗？
在做生意，
做生意是从我公公的大生意里面分出了一小支给我，
然后我现在在做，
那你攒点私房钱了没有啊，
攒了大概有10万吧，
那还得努努力啊，
你这都8年了，
就攒了10万呢，
对，
其实前面有钱，
前面刚结婚第二年就准备买车了，
因为我结婚的时候就没要车，
没要房，
只要了彩礼，
但是因为我老公去做生意了，
他是开了个小厂子，
但是倒闭了，
赔了大概30万，
也是我公公婆婆全部去还的，
我老公也还了，
但是很少很少，
那你得对公公婆婆得比对你亲弟亲妈好才行，
是我的孩子也全部都是我婆婆在照顾，
我每天就是睡醒之后我们不住在一起，
我公公婆婆搂着孩子睡，
我和我老公住在我们的婚房里睡，
现在因为我的弟媳妇要嫁进来了，
我老公的弟弟的弟媳妇也要嫁进来了，
我就不知道该怎么平衡关系，
我自己的心态我觉得是这样啊，
谁对你好，
你对谁好，
谁对你掏心掏肺，
你对谁掏心掏肺，
你不要主动掏。
好，
你被动的等待，
不要主动讨好，
就是龙飞我自己的人生经验吧，
我不主动讨好，
反正就是说不管是妯娌关系啊，
还是什么关系啊，
我不主动讨好，
我就是被动的等待，
看你为人处事怎么样，
看你对我怎么样，
你对我好我就对你好了，
反正我也不靠着你吃，
也不靠着你穿，
反正我现在就应该讨好的人是我公公婆婆，
因为我缺实靠着公公婆婆吃，
他们都说你妈都这样了，
你还对她送礼，
你每年回家还要买四五千块钱的礼品送给她，
你干嘛呀？
你有钱烧的，
我说果没钱，
都是我婆婆买的，
说你婆婆真好，
我觉得你下次跟婆婆也可以发自内心的聊聊天，
说妈，
我是嫁过来了之后才觉得我自己是真的像一个闺女一样被宠爱，
我以前都没有感受过你要这个话说到你婆婆心里去的话，
你婆婆不是还得宠你，
还得对你好，
你看知道你的感恩了，
知道你识好歹了，
我就是有点不识好歹，
我觉得是不是我要的彩礼少，
因为他要16万，
他还要买8万块钱的5斤，
我要不要这去干嘛？
你多花了8年的钱，
你多吃了8年的饭，
你多占了8年的便宜，
你不要去给比那个，
你应该这么说，
你说妈，
隔壁村的那个张姐说，
哎呀，
说弟媳妇儿那个要的彩礼比我高，
说问我会不会不高兴，
妈，
你知道我怎么回答她的吗？
可是我比她多享八年的福呀，
妈，
你多疼了我八年呀，
所以我没有什么不高兴的，
你这么说。
啊，
老人觉得这儿子要懂事儿，
因我现在就感觉这样，
就是我妈对我好一点，
我就说我妈真好，
我婆婆对我那么好，
我还有点不知足，
我就是有姐妹说我不知足，
我就是不知足，
你可真的一定要学会这一招啊，
端谁的碗吃谁的饭，
心里要门儿清啊，
要不然的话是好好的日子，
你到时候婆婆不疼你了，
公公不照顾你们了，
那你好好的日子不就白瞎了吗？
我婆婆和我公公管我们就是管的特别多，
我们基本上就是什么时候吃饭，
什么时候洗衣服，
他们都要告诉我们一声，
你该洗衣服了，
你该换床单被罩了，
就要告诉我们一声你。
当然他们可能是好意，
就是顺嘴说出来，
也习惯照顾别人了，
就这事儿都还要人家提醒你们，
你们也太巨婴了吧，
我们换了就是我不不我，
你换了吗？
那么热了，
你要不热，
你要不要换床来没让我就给你买个新的吧，
我说不用不用，
我用以前的就行，
不用买新的，
你可真是不识好歹啊，
就像那样，
你亲妈亲爹都不怎么管你，
不怎么那个什么你的，
你反而那个什么像这个真心实意真金白银照顾你们，
真金白银养活你们的，
还关心你们的人，
你还挑上理了，
你真的是不识好歹呢，
你所以对我就想让人骂我一顿，
我跟我娘家就是基本上就是一年回去两次，
我不主动跟他们打电话，
因为我每次跟我妈沟通，
我心里就气的睡不着觉，
反正你爸你妈再提什么要求的话，
你就说，
妈，
我也想啊，
你以为。
不想忙，
我也想帮我弟弟啊，
可是我没钱，
我现在都还在啃老，
吃的喝的用的都是公公婆婆出的钱，
我确实我张不开嘴呀，
我不可能张嘴让我公公婆婆支持我弟弟结婚吧，
也没有这个理儿啊，
我只能说说话对，
我妈还问我准备给我弟弟随多少，
我也不知道该随多少，
三千两千，
两三千块就撑死了吧，
那在一个月钱收入两三千块，
对呀，
行好嘞，
那我就跟我妈这边再赚点，
我朋友告诉我，
你跟你妈再不轻点，
你妈现在还想打压你，
还想从你那捞好处，
你就跟你妈再冷一点，
他终于给你妈再冷一点脸，
他们就不欺负你了，
就这意思啊，
好，
那他再告诉我，
他说你弟弟快订婚了，
你要帮帮你弟弟操操心，
我说我没办法，
我很忙，
我帮不了，
没钱，
嗯，
不行，
这样啊，
拜拜，
人哦，
就一定要识好歹哦，
只有识好歹的人才有好日子过哦，
如果不识好歹的话，
再好的日子，
金发碗在面前的话都端不住啊。
真的，
刚才那个妹妹一定要把你的大部分时间精力去说一些窝心的话，
做一些暖心的事儿，
让公公婆婆觉得你是那个好儿媳妇儿，
你是那个不计较的，
你是那个不挑事儿的，
你当妈了，
你都知道，
哪怕手心手背都是肉，
都是亲生的。
这两个孩子也有一个是你偏爱的，
因为那个孩子他讨好你啊，
他窝心啊，
他关心你啊，
他真疼你啊，
你也会对他偏心。
明白吗？
但公公婆婆的偏心可是带真金白银的偏心啊，
公公婆婆的偏心可是正儿八经的真金白银的呀，
情绪价值一定要给到位，
一定要塑造出你是那个不争不抢的，
你是那个知恩图报的，
你是那个觉得公公婆婆已经顶好顶好了的，
你是那个不挑他们理的。
记得点赞关注哦。